hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to the first episode of game
programming so this is an entirely new
series that I'm that I'm doing and
basically the goal of the series is to
make again kind of like Ramallah mount
God from scratch in in Java and the I
guess the goal really of this series is
to teach you guys every single line of
code that goes into making a game like
realm of the mad God so um we will be
making it completely from scratch in
pure Java we're not going to use any
libraries we're going to build built
entire game engine from scratch by
ourselves and every video is going to be
quite short right I want to try and keep
every video under 5 minutes
um maybe preferably around 3 minutes and
and will only add a few lines of code
per video but we will completely discuss
them and I'm gonna make sure that you
guys understand every single line of
code that you guys are writing so that
you actually learn something and you
know it can go on and make your own
games based on our based on this series
so um yeah I'm gonna try and put out a
video every day right every day maybe
like a 3 minute video where we just add
a few lines of code so yeah let's let's
just jump into it so I'm using an IDE an
integrated development environment
called Eclipse now you can download
eclipse it's free the link is in the
description to download it in my opinion
it's the best IDE for Java you can ever
use we're using Java by the way so um
yeah doesn't guys I did imagine that so
once you do actually get eclipse once
you download it and unzip it you can't
really install it but you just unzip it
to you know preferred location um you'll
get this view and all you have to do is
hit workbench right here on top right
now this is actually um this is actually
indigo right there's a new version I
don't like it so I'm going to be using
indigo for this so if you want to follow
along exactly with this I suggest you
download the indigo version imma Helius
is also great I don't like the new one
though it's gonna just don't like it so
I hit workbench and you'll get created
with this now in this case you'll see
that we're actually in Java ie we don't
want to use that we want to use Java
right so hit this little button called
open perspective if you see Java EE here
and then hit Java and that's it and also
try to Java now I'm just going to
organize this slightly right
so I'm I want to assume that you guys
have minimal knowledge if you know at
all knowledge of Java so we're going to
sort of take things from the top so Java
operates on a class-based system like a
file based system so in other words you
have groups of code in separate files or
as they're called in Java classes so we
need to create a class to start off
programming right we're conscious
program here this is can't do this you
have to make a file to actually contain
all your all your code in it so I hit
file hit new and hit Java project that's
the first thing we need to do we're
gonna make a new Java project now I'm
just going to call this um I don't
really have a name for this game so I'm
gonna go ahead and call it rain okay we
might add some rain or something to
justify that but I'm just going to call
it rain again this is just a name of
your Java project you can name this
anything you want hit finish now we've
got approach
I'm actually going to open up a new view
so if you go window show view and then
I'm a navigator you'll actually get more
of like a folder structure and I
actually prefer this to the package
Explorer so we have a few armed
different folders we don't need to worry
about any of this except for the source
folder the source folder is where our
source code is so right click on that
hit new and hit class now we're going to
create a class for our arm for our game
so what I want to do right now is
actually put it inside a package now our
package is like a folder structure it's
like a hierarchy so it's cut it's quite
a convention in Java to actually use
like your internet domain name as a um
as like a folder structure sure so in
other words I own the domain the Cherno
com so what I'm going to do is hit com
dot the Cherno right
and basically what dots are a new
folders is the same thing in Windows
Explorer if you did backslash or four
slash it's a new folder in Java they're
dots or in this case in packages Java
packages they're dots get another dot
and what it's going to call this rain
right SOCOM is comrade the channels like
our domain name and then rain is um the
name of our project right and that's it
we'll just leave it right there in the
root folder of our project and we're
going to name the class um I'm just
going to name it game right this is
going to be our main class which will
actually run the game right there's a
few things that I don't like about this
I don't that I'm going to change right
now first of all I'm gonna hit window
preferences and under general
I want to go ahead and go to editors and
then text editors and hit show line
numbers okay this is just a prep this is
just a personal preference I do like
seeing line numbers it's great for
debugging if you get an error saying
that there's an error line 196 for
example you will immediately know where
that is and you won't actually have to
you know try and find it or click on the
click on the link to it and that's
probably it I'm also going to actually
increase the font so under appearance
colors and fonts I'm just going to go
ahead and under Java there's a Java
editor tax form let's double click on
that I'm going to just set it to courier
new and probably about like maybe 14
sighs just so you guys can see a bit
better all right I don't actually like
programming in such a large font but um
this will help you guys out so yeah so
now we have line numbers and this is all
setup the next thing to do is we're just
gonna actually start coding the game
itself so I am gonna add a few lines of
code this video or even though we're way
over time but this really is the first
video and I do want to actually write
something so essentially what we've done
is we've declared a package right we've
had it we have a package declaration
which says that the package for this
class is calm sure no rain right so if
you look over here now navigator you'll
actually see that there's a folder
inside source called calm right there's
a folder inside calm called Chano
then there's a folder inside the channel
called rain and rain and then inside
rain does this class called game Java
which is what we just created now we
declare the class is a public class
public class game and then inside inside
these two curly brackets is where our
whatever all of our code for this class
is inside of so first thing we'll do is
once once we've sort of thought of a
game we actually need to declare a few
things so first of all the thing that I
like to start off with is the size you
know how big is this game gonna be like
in terms of the window for the game
what's the resolution of the window
right let's start off with screen
resolution so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to type public static int
width and I'm going to set that equal to
300 and I'll explain all this in a
second now first of all public means
that it can be accessed throughout our
entire project so whatever class were in
we can access this width variable right
static means that for this class
essentially what static means is that
for this game class it's going to remain
the same so if we have multiple
instances of the game class width is
always going to equal 300 it's not going
to change now we won't have static in
static references we want to have static
in sorry we will not have instances of
the game class will only have one
instance of the game class we will not
have multiple instances so static isn't
really necessary but what Sally does is
it actually enables us to use with in
another class without actually you know
creating an instance of the game or
object so yeah integer int means that
it's an integer so it's not it doesn't
have decimal it's not like 300 point -
it's just 300 it's an integer and width
is the name of our variable alright and
we've set that equal to 300 so another
word in other words we've created the
variable called width with the value of
300 next thing we'll do is do the same
do the same thing for height now I don't
really know what height I want it to be
right but what I do know is that I want
it to be in a 16:9 aspect ratio so what
I can do is simply say that the height
is equal to width divided by 16 times 9
so essentially I'm working out
the height to be you know whatever
whatever is 16:9 based on the width 300
and that's actually really important in
Java in any programming language you
don't actually have to work everything
out by yourself you can let the computer
actually solve stuff like this for you
and that's a great it's great tier for
programming because a lot of people will
go ahead and open up um and open up a
calculator and type in 300 you know
divided by 16 times 9 and be like okay
it's 168.75 I'm going to pop that in
here now you could it would give you the
same result but it's much faster and
it's much more readable to leave it like
that good because for example in the
future if you wanted to change the
aspect ratio to 1610 you could simply
just do this and that's it you're done
so yeah now we're going with an hi
variable I want to create a scale
variable so public static int scale
equals 3 now what I've done here is I've
essentially just created a variable that
will contain how how much our actual
game will get scaled up to now because
we're using pure Java and we're not
actually going to involve the graphics
card at all here we we don't we don't
really have room to you know create a
high resolution game here what's not
going to do like a retro-style game you
know you could say like well in the math
God because that looks fairly fairly
retro
so essentially what I've done here is
I'm gonna what I want what I'm going to
do in the future is scale up this width
and height by 3 so I'm going to multiply
the width and height variables by 3 in
certain areas in areas to make the
window so essentially our window will be
900 pixels wide and then the equivalent
in height based on 16:9 aspect ratio um
but we're only going to actually render
for 300 pixels so what we'll get is
something that's actually three times
larger than our current window but um
the performance will be as if it was 300
pixels wide so yeah
again what if we're finding all of this
is public static and they're all
integers and we've created three
variables in this video and step set one
and we set values to them so next
episode we'll take a look at continuing
with our game so hope you enjoyed the
video hit the like button if you did and
I'll see you guys later bye